la movilización de este 25 de noviembre
se da en un contexto muy sensible de
mucha indignación por los recientes
casos de feminicidio de Ariadna Fernanda
de debani de Lidia Gabriela
Dinos Lindsay Por qué estás hoy aquí en
esta marcha justamente estoy aquí porque
nos siguen matando y porque no hace nada
porque nos siguen desapareciendo y no
hacen nada Y si nadie nos quiere
escuchar nosotros vamos a tomar las
calles y vamos a tomar las medidas
necesarias para que podamos exigir
nuestros derechos por eso estoy aquí
Gracias también está Jacqueline
Jacqueline qué quieres expresar hoy aquí
en esta marcha que es ver indignante que
nos sigan matando que nadie nos haga
caso y estamos aquí para tomar las
calles para alzar la voz por las que ya
no están y por las que aún estamos y no
queremos ser una cifra más gracias a
pesar de que en todo el país existe el
delito de feminicidio tipificado en los
códigos penales existen alertas de
género hay fiscalías especializadas la
violencia contra las mujeres no cesa es
por ello que miles alzan la voz en esta
marcha sobre Paseo de la Reforma hacia
el zócalo de la Ciudad de México